this is a production of Cornell
University
oh I would like to start uh the story
from this Global carbon budget figure in
the upper part of this figure is the
anthropogenic emissions by fossil fuels
and the land use change what we call
carbon sources and on the on the lower
part of this figure is the destinations
the three destinations of those
anthropogenic emissions including ocean
land and atmosphere let's focus on the
lensing here
um so first of all you may notice an
increasing Trend um this is due to the
CO2 fertilization effect
um and also apart from this increasing
Trend you can also see large
year-to-year vibrations which we call
intranal vibrations of this lensing and
this is largely regulated by climate
vibrations
so with such a large internal vibration
and climate impact remember how about
the future so under the climate change
change in the future well this plant
carbon sink can still offsite our carbon
emissions
so to answer this question people
usually use our system models to
simulate vegetation Dynamics and the
carbon Exchange and so here is a
prediction from different models you can
see that although most of the models can
fit the historical data well they have
large uncertainties for future
projections
also if you look at this figure this um
shows the carbon circumstation across
the latitude you can also see a large
uncertainties especially in tropics
so why because uh because those large
uncertainties many results from
imperfect representation of resist
models for example the climate
interactions between climate and
vegetation
um we have because we have limited
knowledge with so we need to um to know
where to get those knowledge about the
climate vegetation feedback
um so actually the observations of
international variations they provide a
great opportunity for us to understand
how vegetation and climate are
interacted especially to find out the
key regions that controls the land
carbon sink vibrations and we can
quantify their climate sensitivities
um to do that
um I here I plotted the
global global time series time series of
net bios Theory exchange between
atmosphere and uh and the land and
here's you can see that there are ups
and downs mostly regulated by climate
evaluations such as Amino and Ina events
and here I also plotted the topic the
signal from Tropics you can see that the
tropics are dominantly control and
contribute to the internal vibration of
global mbb
and further I also separated the two
major types of ecosystems in Tropics the
tropical rainforests and tropical
semi-air ecosystems here I qualify their
contribution their their separate
contribution to the global signal I
found that tropical Seminary the
ecosystems have a higher a much higher
contribution to the tropical rainforests
uh compared to the tropical rainforest
but if we account for the area
difference we actually see a much higher
contribution per area in those tropical
rainforests than the tropical semi-arid
ecosystems
um so basically the analysis here show
uh shows that um shows the importance of
both types of ecosystems in tropics and
we need to separately quantify their
climate sensitivities of net biosphere
Exchange
but before we do that there is one more
step
um think about the components of net
biosphere exchange
um so actually it is composed of
different carbon fluxes including gpp
the photosynthesis at ecosystem level
and respiration and fires
and these individual component may be
governed by different mechanisms so we
need to quantify them separately and and
then evaluate their separately evaluate
their Amino sensitivities
um but it is not very easy to qualify
those individual carbon fluxes for
example let's take GBP as an example so
usually we use anti-covariance flexover
to measure net system exchange and then
this can be further partition into gpp
and respiration based on certain
assumptions so here this photo shows a
flexor will be our group installed in at
Musgrave Farm
and usually we consider such
measurements of gpp and respiration as
ground truth the issue of such approach
is that
um they can only measure at the local
ecosystem with limited spatial scale
um and those towers are not globally
distributed if you look at this global
distribution of flux Towers you can see
that actually the majority of the
majority of the regions in Tropics are
are blank with limited sites and and
this is the region of our interest of
this study so
to overcome this issue people sometimes
use remote sensing satellites to provide
additional information for example those
satellites can usually measure
Reflections at different wavelengths and
then to calculate vegetation indices
such as ndvi and DVI from those
reflectance those vegetation indices are
mostly grain is based
and because those um those satellite
measurements are globally available so
therefore can be used for upscaling
those Flex Tower measurements
the issue of such approach is that those
vegetation indices cannot fully capture
the variation of gpp for example as the
figure showed up as the figure shows
here you can see that those four
vegetation indices commonly used
vegetation indices does not have enough
expanded power for estimating GBP and
some ways also with non-linear
relationship
uh
there there was a new game changer on
the shift called solar induced the
chlorophyll fluorescence a new
vegetation signal and here is a here is
the first global map
um of Civ retrieved from satellite goes
at
and furthermore people found that there
was a a great linear relationship
between gpp and Civ
so um this means this suggests that safe
may provide a promising pathway for gpp
estimation
and so what is it
so Sif is um safe is called solar
induced chlorophyll for lessons and when
lights are absorbed by chlorophylls and
some of the energy will be used for
photosynthesis and some will be
dissipated as heat and very small
portion of the energy will be uh
it will be reimitted out of the
vegetation and that is
chlorophyll fluorescence so
and safe is an optical signal and here
is the spectrum of safe mostly covering
red and far red region
and safe is in particular useful for
estimating gpp because it contains both
structural information like how much
light is absorbed in total and the
functional information how those energy
was partitioned into different pathways
and think about let's look at those on
these two conceptual equations that are
usually used for estimating gpp and Civ
so gpp can be estimated
um estimated uh by the product of part
the photosynthetically active radiation
and times F part the fraction of power
being used and then times a light use
efficiency term and safe can be modeled
in a similar way with slightly slightly
use efficiency term replaced with that
Forsyth and times a factor Epsilon to
account for the probability of safe
escaping from the canopy
and here as I showed um so it basically
contains two kinds of information the
structure information has represented as
part so this kind of information can
usually represented and estimated by
vegetation indices
um but for light use efficiency
information such functional information
can only be provided by safe uniquely so
that's why in the previous slide we see
a better scalability of of gpp of safe
to gpp and in addition
um also because of this functional
information safe has better capability
of early draft or early stress and
detection because those functional
changes usually occurred earlier than
those structural changes
and another advantage of Sif is that
safe only capture the signal from active
radioactive vegetation so it is free
from contamination signal from soil
which is a common issue for for
traditionally use the vegetation indices
is also less sensitive to aerosols and
the thin clouds if I benefited from its
retrieval approach
um but stiff is not perfect there are
many issues in the original satellite
retrievals for example here this come to
satellite provides safe and very coarse
special resolution about 40 by 40
kilometers squared
and this one the also two
um it it was launched in 2014 and it
provides it provides very fine spatial
resolution
but the issue is that it all the data
holding covers very narrow narrow
satellite tracks here we start spatial
gaps between the satellite tracks
and and here uh performing another
satellite sensor that provides safety
travel at pretty good spatial resolution
and with global coverage but the issue
of its time span it it was launched in
2014 so that's something 18 so it cannot
increase back to the previous Time
series
so in order to evaluate the long-term
climate the sensitivities of vegetation
we need to first to develop along a high
resolution globally contiguous long-term
safe records first which is my chapter
chapter one
um to achieve this goal uh we did
several projects for example the first
one we
um we did some we did the Gap feeling
work for Oco tools if so if you remember
this uh this the issue of this satellite
is the large spatial gaps and you can
see those are satellite tracks and the
those uh those those regions within the
between the tracks are are missing for
for the data
and here we use machine learning
algorithm to fill those uh spatial gaps
and generate a globally Contigo
contiguous safe map
and
and for the second project we used a
similar framework but here we to we we
want to downscale the uh the safety
travels from gong to and scamaki which
means to make it a finer resolution
because the original safety retrievals
from those two satellites are pretty
coarse
um so here we use uh similar uh machine
learning algorithm to um to downscale
those products so here you can see that
our downscaled say products can greatly
capture the fine spatial resolution the
spatial resolution original sift but
providing more special details
and here I would like to briefly
introduce the framework we employed for
the both projects so here we for both
projects we utilize a strategy that
combines machine learning and Physiology
physiological constraints specifically
for both projects we
um we use multi-7 band reflex surface
reflectance as predictors which is
provided at find spatial resolution and
with global coverage so we first
resample that to match the save along
orbits or safe at the course resolution
and then feed them into the machine
learning model and after the model was
calibrated we we then use the fine
resolution predictors the multi-surface
reflectance will generate a global safe
map at 0.05 degree
and for the second project we also use a
data Fusion technique to merge the two
data sets together to generate a
long-term record from 2002 to 2018.
and especially
considering that um those predictors the
surface Reflections may only May promote
a lot of it provide a lot of information
about this
structural uh structural function but
not much about the functional
information so in this work with we
stratified our machine learning models
by time and biome or time on the and the
space
um to implicit the constraint such land
use efficiency information in our
product
um so we did a number of applications
with different data sources first of all
first of all we validate our products
with original
satellite safely travels
um
um hair or particular downscaled safe as
an example so we we aggregate it back to
the course resolution compared with the
original safe measurements we found that
they match pretty well and here shows
the spatial map of prediction residual
the difference between observations and
the predictions
so we show that our downscaled Safe
products can greatly preserve the
spatial and temporal vibrations of
original safety travels and after that
we also did some validation work with
independent Airborne measurements
this Airborne data was collected from
various systems ecosystems in like in
North America and North America
including problems and the forests and
those Airborne measurements are provided
at very very fine spatial resolution so
we aggregated that to 0.05 degree to
match our downskilled product
and here we show that our downscaled
safe product can successfully capture
the fine spatial variation revealed by
the Airborne data
and finally we also did some validation
with independent ground measurements
to validate its temporal vibration here
we selected the the ground data was
collected from a tower installed at a
conifer forest in diamond ridge
and an important a special feature of
this um this Forest is that you can see
here in panel B there are strong uh
seasonality in gpp and shift but when
you look at greenness or light
absorption we don't see such a nice
strong seasonality this is because when
you think about these conceptual
equations this is because those forests
are mainly driven by functional changes
like the like the light use efficiency
but the structural structure but not
much about the instructional changes
like green is
so in this work uh in this part we
compared our downscaled safe product in
uh in black dots here we found that
um our downscaled product can greatly
capture the temporal vibrations due to
the functional changes which means our
products can can successfully capture
that those functional information
although we use the reflectance as the
predictors
um so with this product we actually we
employed uh explored a lot a number of
applications for example in my chapter
three I evaluate a trial and vegetation
Dynamics in response to water
availability
and in my chapter four I used the
zip data to quantify the carbon optic
and evaluate climate sensitivities in
tropical rainforests
and we also um because safe is highly
correlated with vegetation productivity
so we also try to use save data to
estimate crop productivity and yield in
U.S Corn Belt and India beat belt
and they also tried um it's uh explored
its applications in Social economics for
example in this project we um we
collaborated with professors at Dyson
school and the department Department of
Statistics to
um to use safe along other predictors to
predict the poverty and the malnutrition
problems in some food insecure countries
in Africa and Asia
because those countries are highly
agricultural based so those index
prevalence those predictors so those
poverty predictors poverty indicators
can be highly associated with
agricultural productivity therefore can
be estimated by self
and and also we uh we use the safe data
to evaluate uh the land restoration
project uh Land by World Bank a world
Bank in Ethiopia so this is so far the
most ambitious such project in the world
in this study we found that such
programs can greatly enhance the drug
resilience in those lands
and if you have further interest I would
highly recommend you to raise the two
companion reviews about safe Theory data
and applications our group published
last year
um so after uh chapter one I would like
like to briefly introduce my chapter two
um so in this project we actually
originally
um
planned to construct a full diamond
cycle of safe from oso3 so osco3 is
another satellite sensor that provides
safety retrievals a very very special
feature is is the dyno sampling strategy
as you can see here in the illustration
so while most of the satellites provide
acquired data at the at the same time of
day for each for for each overpass so
this satellite can Pro can Will acquire
data at different times of day for each
different overpass therefore can
providing important information about
the diurnal variation
um but uh we changed our plan and we
ended up under the web up with construct
doing a similar work but to construct a
full download cycle of land surface
temperature and eventful transpiration
from ecostrust so equal stress is a new
generation Mission led by NASA for water
monitoring it measures our St and the
estimate ET at very high spatial
resolution at subfield scale and because
uh equals the sensors of equal stress
and oco3 are both mounted on
International Space Station and takes a
similar uh some Dyno sampling strategy
so our developed work framework here can
be potentially used for constructing of
sales three
um but I will not introduce the much
details about this because this is a
little bit uh not relevant to my main
topic but if you have interest you are
welcome to my exam next Wednesday
morning in amazon133
and next I would like to introduce how I
use the those reconstructed zip products
to evaluate vegetation Dynamics and
climate sensitivities remember in the
very beginning we we showed that large
uncertainties in those model simulations
so we would like to use the observations
of Internet vibrations to constrain
those models so for chapter three I I
did some work to uh in the tropical
tropical dry lands here I specifically
interested about the dry lands in form
of Africa so this region is becoming uh
increasingly increasingly uh
increasingly hard research topic not
only because it's vulnerability to
climate change but also due to its
social economic importance for example
if there has been a persistent food
insecurity issues due to for agriculture
management long-standing land
degradation and an increase in
population Nation
and many such observations have been
used for vegetation monitoring and
thought detection
however there have been there there are
some limitations in previous studies for
example limitation one they mostly
evaluated the green is based indices
such as ndbi and so in this work we
employed a number of six data sets to
evaluate vegetation Dynamics in this
region including original safe uh
satellite safe from tropomy
a satellite sensor and several
reconstructed zip products using machine
learning algorithms
and limitation Tool uh there there is
little ground data available for
validation
this region is very uh it's a very data
poor region
um so in this work our collaborators
have installed a ground station a tower
station to collect data for validation
and reference for satellite data sets
specifically the site is located in
southern Kenya
um the uh they are covered the site is
covered by Seminary vegetation mostly
grass and with some sharp straps and
isolated trees and there are two major
grading stations a short reading season
from October to the 14th January and the
the long-range station from March to
June
so um so first I I would like to go
through the internal vegetation Dynamics
with you um during uh typically normal
year so this year from September 2018 to
August 2019 uh here on the low on the
upper part of this figure I chose the
print station in light blue vertical
bars they mostly occurred during the two
Renaissance as I'm marking the x-axis
here and the corresponding if you look
at the two soil moisture products the
soil monster has also have two peaks
during the two rainy seasons and the the
the peak during the long reading season
is a little bit lower than the first
Peak
and then I've evaluated the vegetation
Dynamics so here
um hair shows the three reconstructed
zip products we can see that they also
showed two peaks with the higher peak in
the short raining season
and we also plotted the uh the safe
measurements from tropomy in the black
dots because the original data has a lot
of noise so I take the moving average in
Black curve here
um we can see that the the temporal
vibration is pretty consistent between
the tropommissive and those
reconstructed zip products
and also I plotted the vegetation
indices from all this including and our
ndbi and arv we also see such such two
peaks and raise a higher peak in the
short ranging season
it seems that the safe and the
vegetation products can greatly track
the internal vibrations
in vegetation Dynamics in response to in
response to water availability
but let's move to the next year
um depending from 2019 to 2020. so this
year the site experience anomalously
high principation and you can also find
the high storm persistently High slow
moisture from basically from October to
next to the 14th May
and because of this uh when we look at
the registration signals uh from like
here from reconstruct itself from to
promise and from different vegetation
indices from all these
we also a higher country a higher
overall a stronger vegetation signal in
response to a higher soil moisture
content even in this short grading
season between the between the two rainy
Seasons we can see that the soil
moisture and vegetation signals are
still pretty high compared to normal
years
but interesting interestingly we found
some differences among different
satellite products for example here we
see that for tropomy this black curve we
found a sharp reduction starting from
November and persists till early early
February and about 41 percent of the
reduction and maybe look at the
reconstructive uh here in here if you
look at here and you know they only
showed a very mild reduction in the in
the early of the in early November and
recovered quickly
and for as for the modest vegetation
indices we don't even see such reduction
we see a slight increase
so luckily we have the ground data for
validation and reference so here in the
upper upper curve I showed in safe
yourself
uh we found it shows a similar reduction
as tropomy both in magnitude and in in
the duration
so next this makes us wonder what
happened there um what happened to such
reduction because because if you look at
the soil moisture
um during this region is the soil water
is very high and so it's certainly not
water stressed and when we look at the
essential light absorption uh we also we
only see a very mild reduction about 13
percent
and finally we found some clues in the
cameras in the photos taken by the
interior cameras for example this is a
photo taken on the first Peak and here
here is uh here's the photo taking on
the tip about mid-December and they
found that actually some of the crosses
proceeded to the product reproductive
stage and therefore the the
photosynthesis activity decreased during
this period during this period and after
that
um because of excessive water
availability and another new ground uh
another another new round of
phenological cycle started here and you
can see the uh photosense activity
increase again
so that that explains uh such a
reduction and increase during this
period and so in summary we found that
such a faster change in Internet
vegetation Dynamics due to phenological
changes can only be captured by two
promises
and uh and in this project we also
utilize
um different products to to investigate
intran new vegetation Dynamics to see
how soil moisture and Frank station
regulates the vegetation productivity
so here I chose the principation
um internal vibrations for short
draining season and long rainy season
and here shows the soil moisture you can
see they both match pretty well with
each other and here I chose the
vegetation indices by safe and the NR
nirv they are also highly correlated but
interestingly when I calculated the
correlation between principation soil
monster and vegetation signals I found
an isometrical response um here let me
explain that so this figure shows the
spark plug shows the
the correlation between safe and the
constipation and so much right the left
two bars are the correlation between
um between the uh between shift and the
prince station we see a much higher
correlation
um for uh for Prince for presentation uh
about 0.9 but for soil moisture we only
see a correlation of 0.7
but when we when we move on to the lung
rainy season we see that the pattern
just got reversed
we say a a lower correlation with Point
solution but a higher uh correlation
with uh with a based soil moisture
and this also holds for all the other
vegetation signals like vegetation
indices and other Safe products
so why oh we would like to explain that
so our hypothesis is that during the
short rainy season
um the soil monitor is very low after a
long dry season from July to September
therefore um principation Can instant
instant instantly instantly stimulate
saturation growth
but for long brainy season some some of
the water may be carried over from the
preceding raining season for example as
we saw in 2020 and those part of the
water can be utilized by plants
um especially those with relatively
deeper Goods
um so
to test our hypothesis We compare the
soil moisture profile
um at the beginning of long-rangeas and
the short raining season here so we we
do found that uh for for short rainy
season at the beginning of short raining
season there is much lower so much
moisture content compared to lung
raining season
especially in the top layers on top like
50 centimeters and those layers uh the
water in those layers are very critical
for vegetation growth especially for the
grasses in at this site
and as for implications because previous
Studies have have shown that
um there might be a productive
precipation principation shift from long
rainy season to short rainy season in
the future
so such as magical response between long
releases and short-raining season should
be considered in the in the model
simulations
so that's that's for chapter three
and in chapter four I further evaluated
the climate sensitivities of tropical
rainforest and in this project I
specifically look at the difference
between arms and Congo rainforest with
the two largest tropical rainforests in
the world
and there are some studies that already
reported the inherent differences
between the two regions for example in
this figure in this paper uh they found
a difference in white choices and
contrast between the two regions so here
this map shows the um difference between
safe between the productivity
the difference is in productivity
between devices and the dry season so
here you can see that for Amazon regions
the majority the majority of the region
shows are twice as an increase in
productivity
the whole region basically show a deep
productivity decreased during the
devices compared to the wet season
and furthermore this is also also
attributed to such differences to
hydrological difference hydroclimate
difference especially the annual
principation and with the principle with
the threshold 2000 millimeters
and
and also there are some ground studies
like there are some studies with ground
measurements showing differences in
microecology in those two tropical
forests for example from here we show
that um so Amazon is in this blue shape
and the Congo is in this orange shape
you see that Congo has a much smaller
spacious richness and smaller and less
stem density which means less trees but
with a higher carbon stocks
so this makes me wonder whether the two
tropical rainforests have differences in
their internal climate sensitivities and
environmental control so in this paper I
evaluate such differences
so here I would like to briefly
introduce the data sets I used still
think about the different components of
MBE so for MBE I use four atmospheric
inversion data data products and for gpp
I use the three gpp products based on
safe and reflectance and fires from a
commonly used fire database and the
respiration because
um there is no um great Global graded
respiration data data product so we just
calculate that as the budgeted residual
of all the other carbon fluxes carbon
component fluxes and for methodology we
employed a novel causal influence
framework because instead of like
conventionally use the correlation based
metrics because we believe such
correlation based metrics such as Vector
correlation or or partial correlation
can be susceptible to autocorrelation
and collinity among different or system
or system of variables such as carbon
fluxes and environmental drivers
um so here shows our results uh this uh
this figure shows the environmental
control of gpp from air temperature
part the light radiation APD and the
soil moisture so here please uh pay
attention to the horizontal bar which is
the average across different data
products so here we see that the both
both reinforest doesn't show a strong
sensitivity to air temperature
but they have a differential response to
other variables for example compared to
Amazon and Congo shows a lower
sensitivity sensitivity to power to
light radiation but a stronger
sensitivity to sensitivity to APD and
soil moisture
and especially uh look at the looking at
this soil moisture sensitivity we found
basically there is a zero cause of
strength or zero climate sensitivity in
Amazon well Congo shows a pretty high
climate sensitivity of soil moisture and
we also evaluate nbe and respiration we
also see such pattern
and so this makes us Wonder uh the
wonder about the underlying mechanisms
of such differential soil muscle
response
we came up with two hypothesis uh
hypothesis one is about the differences
in hydroclimate the hypothesis that
Congo May has less water availability
than Amazon therefore vegetation may be
more affected by the soil moisture
deficit
and for a hypothesis 2 uh we we think
maybe the differences differences in Eco
physiology may have the contribution for
example the Congo vegetation may just be
less resistance to water stress as due
to like differences in species plant
trees and vegetation composition
so to test our hypothesis uh first uh to
test the first hypothesis we compare the
hydrological uh variables including for
example here I chose that Amazon has
indeed has a higher principation than
Congo and the higher soil monster and
also higher aridity index so a relative
index is calculated as the ratio of of
transportation and potential UT so
basically the water supply and water
demand and where it's higher uh oh
come back
okay with higher average index ratio a
higher with higher Index this means the
region is better so in summary from
those analysis we found that Congo
indeed has less about availability that
Amazon rainforest rainforest
and for hypothesis 2 so to test this we
need to first to control the first
Factor the differences in hydroclimate
so in this work we
we grouped the pixels in in both regions
into into different ability index groups
and we assume that within each
we had a fire alarm we're back for the
last five minutes or so yeah
thanks for being back safely so
um let me let me think where we got uh
sorry
yeah where are we um
I think we we just talked about the
hypothesis tool so here I I grouped um
the pixels in two regions into the same
uh two different groups uh here uh so we
assume that within the E within this
within the same group uh they're they're
hydroclimate conditions are similar uh
so after we group that control the
control the differences in the hydro
climate we then evaluate uh whether
there are still some differences between
arms and Congo and the answer is yes we
still see such separation here
so this means uh there could be
um
there could be
okay so this means in addition to
hydroclimate factors difference in Hydro
climate factors there might be some
differences in ecophysiology that
contribute to such differential soil
moisture sensitivity between Amazon
Congo
and further we also evaluate the current
state of art model simulations to see
how how they capture
um such differential soil moisture
sensitivities
uh so here this this figure shows the uh
shows the uh how individual models
performed performs in capture the
differences between amps and Congo so
moisture sensitivity and here the
summary of model is in this black
triangle and the observation is in this
green dots so we found that many models
can capture to some degree the
differential response between the two
regions but most of the models just
underestimate that
and to get a clue we also separately
evaluate the two factors of those models
for hydroclement factors because those
models simulate the soil moisture so we
just compare the simulated soil moisture
between the two regions and to compare
the model with our print our
observations so here you can see that
most of the models shows that Amazon has
a higher soil monster
and some even overestimate compared to
the observations
and we also did a similar work a similar
analysis to a grouped uh the pixels in
Amazon Congo in different registry
groups and here we found that actually
uh those models cannot distinguish the
difference between Amazon and Amazon and
Congo here so this is um this is not
surprising because those models usually
assume the two tropical rainforest uh as
the same land as the same plant
functional group and therefore they
ignore their inherent differences in
their vaccination response and
functional like trace and ecosystem
traits
um
yeah so so that's all for this part and
a very quick summary about the whole
analysis the whole research in chapter
one to resolve the limitations of
original satellite retrievals I
developed machine learning using machine
learning algorithms so develop uh high
resolution globally configures and
long-term safe trackers and we tested it
with a number of applications in ecology
Agriculture and social economics and
most importantly we use the um the the
save data to calculate to quantify the
internal new climate sensitivities uh
especially for tropical dry lands and
tropical rainforests
um because those those those ecosystems
are very important to uh Global uh
Global uh the simulation or Earth model
simulations of global current cycle
so specifically for thailands we see a
asymmetrical response to constipation
and soil moisture during the two winning
seasons and for a tropical rainforest we
see that amps and Congo show
differential soil moisture sensitivities
due to both hydroclimate difference and
equal physiology difference and such
difference cannot be fully captured by
the current RCS models
um so yeah that's all and I would like
to express my great gratitude to all my
committee members and also my lab
members and also faculties in Cornell
and external collaborators I would also
acknowledge the founding Source on the
NASA graduate student Fellowship a
number of other NASA fundings thank you
very much and
any questions
[Music]
like 10 kilometers yeah
resolution
sure it works just fine as it is
uh
yeah the original for example the the
one the example I showed uh it has
pretty coarse resolution like 40 by 40
kilometers squared so that's a pretty
course and also later I showed a figure
for comp belt you can see that they are
possibly covered by dozens of pixels
which is not enough high enough
for finding up for the special for the
application so in this work we just use
some machine learning algorithm to try
to improve the data
thanks
for the last chapter is
the Amazon wondering
what so this is a what-it question
um with that difference is the
asymmetrical differences between two
what effect did that have on and what
kind of effect does that have on
what day in a sense from a carbon flux
perspective maybe if you integrated
these differences into these models yeah
they're now getting unified yeah what
kind of response to expect to see yeah
that's a certainly a quick question I
would say that's that's also the future
work we should do we should certainly
incorporate those differences uh into
those current models
um
yeah it's hard to say I think um at this
week I think we can get a more accurate
predictions uh if we make it more
realistic for Amazon and Congo and
actually when I uh look at
um the
the model the the comparison of models
and the sensitivity of models and the
observations I found that actually Congo
is overall well stimulated but there are
a few issues for Amazon and
I think maybe the soil moisture
sensitivity is overestimated in those
regions in those models
um so there is incorporating the
knowledge that we we got here I think we
may see a
larger
carbon sequenceration potential of
Amazon maybe but we need to test
yeah
that's a great question we also yeah
think a lot about the underlying like
more in-depth analysis
um so if you remember in the in the
beginning of this chapter I showed the
ground data shows Congo has Over All
Pure spacious richness which could uh
make it make it less resistant to water
stress and also Congo has a fewer stamps
basically a fewer trees but uh
um but but larger carbon carbon biomass
so that means there might be more larger
trees in fungal and those darker trees
may be more susceptible to water to soil
moisture stress as well and in terms of
soil properties and disorder depths and
we actually did some analysis we found a
global soil adapts data set
there we found maybe Amazon is slightly
has a slightly deeper soil layers so
therefore maybe there may be more water
storage in that region but
Amazon yeah yeah
that's a great question we are also um
have a lot a lot of discussion about
that
um so if you remember if you remember in
the in the methodology the framework I
showed for dance kidding we actually use
a com a strategy that combined the
machine learning and physiological
constraints because we believe those
reflex modest Reflections can only
provide structured information but not
much about the light use efficiency
information so we train the model
um like um research stratified model in
like in local window and local window
and local timestamp therefore the light
use efficiency can be constrained by
implicit implicitly constraint by the
original zip measurements
um
does does that answer your question yeah
thanks
oh yeah I can check
oh Lincoln said let's talk quick
question about last part quality of
preparation paragraphs may have issues
in tropical regions could you come and
conservators and the background oh so
this question oh oh you can see you
can't see that so this question asked
about the last chapter about the quality
of vegetation products in in tropical
regions uh yes that's a and indeed
concern and that's why in the first
um chapter I actually I want to use Sif
um to to do this analysis because we
think safely provide more more accurate
uh quantification or estimation uh for
gpp
um but still we should acknowledge such
uncertainties and also
um not only vegetation products but also
like soil moisture products we also see
larger uncertainties in tropical
rainforests so those are also should be
considered in this analysis thanks
um
yeah so that's the owning question and
thank you very much for being here and
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu